jetzt sind schon 17 menschen durch das
neuartige corona virus in china
gestorben das virus 2009 10 n tv
bereitet sich in china viel schneller
aus als fachleute es befürchtet hatten
jetzt gibt es warnungen dass es sich
auch weltweit ausbreitet es also zu
einer pandemie kommen könnte schnelles
handeln ist jetzt dringend erforderlich
um das schlimmste noch zu verhindern
krieg zum science fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen das thema
saas hatten fachleute weltweit
eigentlich abgeschlossen denn das virus
galt als ausgerottet doch das war ein
irrtum
das virus ist überraschender weise in
einer anderen variante zurückgekommen
ganze 17 jahre später das corona virus
wurde mittlerweile schon in fünf ländern
bestätigt südkorea thailand japan china
und einen ersten fall gibt es jetzt auch
in den vereinigten staaten 440 offiziell
gemeldete infektionen gibt es in china
17 menschen hat es bereits das leben
gekostet sorgen bereitet den behörden
die tatsache dass die zahl der
infizierten innerhalb weniger tage
rasant angestiegen ist alleine von
sonntag bis mittwoch wuchs die
gesamtzahl der erkrankten auf das
siebenfache
dazu sagt der chinesische
gesundheitsminister lieben wir sind nun
in der kritischen phase der bekämpfung
des virus das schneller ansteigen der
zahlen begründet er damit dass man nun
zitat ein tieferes verständnis des virus
und verbesserte diagnostische methoden
habe so wurden jetzt auch die ersten
maßnahmen ergriffen von reisen nach
johann wurde abgeraten die menschen
sollten die hauptstadt der provinz hubei
weder verlassen noch neu aufsuchen es
gibt keine flüge und keine züge mehr
nach und von buhlen die stadt ist
praktisch abgeriegelt und steht unter
quarantäne
doch am kommenden wochenende steht das
chinesische neujahrsfest an und menschen
reisen deswegen hin und her
wahrscheinlich würde es also trotzdem
zumindest fahrten mit privatautos in und
aus der millionenstadt geben
in yuan sind bislang mehr als 80 prozent
der nachgewiesenen infektionen
aufgetreten es wird davon ausgegangen
dass die krankheit dort auf einem
fischmarkt ihren anfang nahm
wir werden nicht nur fische sondern auch
andere tiere gehandelt beispielsweise
kamele bauen und koalabären
der markt schon seit längerer zeit
geschlossen alles vor ort wurde
gereinigt und desinfiziert die
chinesischen behörden gaben außerdem die
anordnung heraus dass die krankenhäuser
alle personen die in engem kontakt mit
infizierten standen festgehalten und
isoliert werden dürfen notfalls auch
gegen ihren willen offenbar ist das
virus doch von mensch zu mensch
übertragbar dazu schreibt das robert
koch institut auf seiner webseite der
whu zufolge bestand basierend auf den
bisher vorliegenden informationen die
möglichkeit einer begrenzten
mensch-zu-mensch-übertragung da sich
eine reihe von erkrankungsfällen nicht
anders erklären ließen
mehrere solcher mensch zu mensch
übertragung wurden am 20
22 von den chinesischen behörden
bestätigt ebenso wie etwa ein dutzend
erkrankungsfälle beim medizinischen
personal weitere begrenzte mensch zu
mensch übertragungen sind zu erwarten
fachleute können mittlerweile eine
pandemie also eine weltweite epidemie
nicht ausschließen doch um diese gefahr
genau einzuschätzen braucht es mehr
informationen über das virus in
berichten ist immer wieder die rede von
einer neuartigen krankheit und eben auch
einem neuartigen corona virus genau
genommen ist es wohl ein neuer typ des
sars corona virus fachleute sind darüber
nicht überrascht sondern können dem auch
etwas positives abgewinnen denn
erkenntnisse aus der bereits
stattgefundenen forschung können jetzt
helfen beispielsweise ist es denkbar
dass fachleute nun bei der entwicklung
von medikamenten die die bereits
geleistete vorarbeit nutzen können dazu
sagt der berliner virologe christian
drosten in einem interview mit
tagesschau 24 wir haben sehr viele vor
befinde und müssen daher viel
grundlagenarbeit gar nicht mehr leisten
in der wissenschaft andererseits müssen
wir die krankheits gestalt wirklich ganz
neu betrachten das heißt nicht nur weil
es mit dem sars virus eng verwandt ist
verläuft auch die krankheit so schwer
wie basars dieses server akute
respiratorische syndrom nahm 2002 seinen
anfang und wird zu den gefährlichsten
infektionswellen jüngster zeit gezählt
die weltgesundheitsorganisation hat
insgesamt 8000 saß fälle registriert und
es gab etwa 800 todesopfer doch es hätte
uns noch viel schlimmer treffen können
doch glücklicherweise war dieses virus
nicht so leicht übertragbar wie
beispielsweise influenza nicht
auszumalen was
passiert wäre hinzu kamen rigorose
interventionsmaßnahmen in den
asiatischen großstädten allerdings erst
nachdem die chinesische regierung den
ausbruch lange zeit unter verschluss
gehalten hatte als ich dann ein
bewusstsein für die krankheit entwickelt
hat sind viele patientinnen und
patienten möglicherweise schon bei den
ersten symptomen zum arzt gegangen und
konnten so isoliert werden das virus war
damals aus dem tierreich zu uns menschen
übergesprungen
doch bis heute sind sich fachleute nicht
sicher ob schleichkatzen oder
fledermäuse die ursprünglichen reservoir
wirte des virus waren auch die neue saas
variante stammt wohl aus ähnlichen
quellen also aus wildtieren mit den
menschen gehandelt haben
doch noch sind keine genauen details
dazu bekannt am mittwochabend hatte die
weltgesundheitsorganisation auf einem
krisentreffen beraten ob aufgrund des
corona virus in china ein weltweiter
gesundheitsnotstand ausgerufen werden
muss das passiert wenn eine solche
mehrere länder bedroht und somit eine
internationale antwort notwendig ist
bisher war das genau fünf mal der fall
2009 10 wegen der ebola epidemie 2016
wegen sieger 2014 gegen polio und ebola
und 2009 wegen der schweinegrippe noch
zögert die wir aber weil sie dem virus
bisher nicht als so gefährlich einstuft
beobachtet aber weiter die lage auch die
deutsche bundesregierung schätzt das
risiko im menschen in deutschland als
sehr gering ein
laut dem gesundheitsminister jens spahn
von der cdu sei das neuartige corona
virus nicht so gefährlich wie der sars
erreger von damals dennoch beobachten
die deutschen behörden die situation
sehr aufmerksam
das robert koch institut hat bislang
noch keine reisewarnung herausgegeben
ist zaz zurück corona virus breitet sich
immer weiter aus anklicken anschauen und
krieg zum science fiction abonnieren wir
halten euch hier dazu natürlich auf dem
aktuellen stand bis dann bleib dran